In 1995, four master software designers documented their knowledge in
a now classical book called Design Patterns. They were Gamma, Helm, Johnson, and
Vlissides. Because of the number of the authors, this book is sometimes called
the Gang of Four book, or simply GOF. After the publication of GOF,
the idea of Design Patterns caught fire in the software design community. And
books and websites have been publishing a variety of related topics,
including analysis and refinement patterns. As well as programming language
specific pattern catalogs. And even a book on anti-patterns,
which are common problems to avoid. The resources page, of the class
includes a citation of the Gang of Four book as well as Alexander's book.
And a pointer to a website which has a catalog of such software design patterns